The knights never have a horse, never have a weak exploratory.
I once stole some horses. They were my uncles. And as for you, mind your own business.
I said, Temujin, now, son, try to be a worthy leader for our people.
Good lead, I bet his son Temujin is still too young.
Who would kneel in allegiance to a little child?
I, Tagutai, will be the new chief.
Be the chief, the chief's son always succeeded. He will soon be a man and you must obey him.
You can stay here and bow down to a little child. But I'm leaving, I'll take my tribe with me.
I'm your friend, and I'll stay with you. I can be useful. You'll see. Look how strong I am.
Our future won't be easy. There are only a few goats left and some sheep.
We still have eight horses and the oxen that can pull our wagon. Life will be difficult.
Oh, we'll be all right.
Your father and ruler of the Kinjit people was a descendant of the great Mongol.
You have to remain strong and united because one day all of our territory we will regain.
My eldest son Temujin will be a great chief, and he will add great conquest to our realm.
And when that time comes, you will see how beautiful the world can be.
Jhin was just about your age when all this happened.
But that little child was going to build one of the world's greatest empires.
You should stay as light as you can. Remove anything that you don't need.
Include water?
Take only your bows and your knives.
Well, plenty to eat.
Hey, for kill the stag.
The big one?
And they're stocky horses.
The Mongols could ride like this at full speed over long distances and for hours and hours nonstop.
Horses.
Son of Yezugai, King of the Kia.
Have you seen a group of tashins come by here with stolen horses?
Yes, they went by when the sun was quite high.
Stole your horses?
Oh, my name is Borchutemujin.
I can see that you're very tired.
And your horse is exhausted.
We Ariolettes have always been loyal friends.
If you don't rest your horse, he's liable to die.
And you too need rest.
Why not sleep now?
And tomorrow at dawn, I will go along with you.
If you are a friend, then let's go now.
There's no time to waste to horse.
Soldier centuries early
tended to flee in the face of three enemies.
He separated them,
then was able to defeat them one at a time.
It was a good trick,
and it worked again.
You're faithful and brave, Boichu.
You'll always be my special friend and companion.
You must die.
I will pardon you if you join us.
Remain weak, and why?
Because we are not united.
Our peoples are constantly at war with one another.
It's always the same.
Together we'd be unbeatable. We'd be able to take the pastures and dominate them.
No Mongol has ever seen such things.
There would be no limit to the territories we could conquer.
Oh, man of wisdom, tell me, how can we unite all of them
when all they want to do is fight one another in never-ending wars?
How?
I suppose you begin using good old superior force on them.
Choose the time and place for each battle.
Make sure that you always have the advantage, and also,
you must apply your intelligence, learn to manipulate your enemy.
He would rather be a little king at home than a great vassal bowing to someone else.
You must also be forever loyal to those who serve you faithfully.
All men respect loyalty.
And plain cunning if everything else should fail.
Mogen, my son, you are 16 now.
You are a man.
It is time for you to marry.
You know that D.A. Session has promised that his daughter Borte will be your bride.
He is a powerful chief.
It would make a good alliance.
Yes, Mother.
Tomorrow I will set off.
Temujin, son of Yesugai, who was, um, was saying Temujin, um...
Were you saying something, Danny Session?
Yes, I was, but you weren't listening.
Your daughter Borte is very beautiful.
So I've been told.
I promised your father Borte is your bride.
Now, what can you give her?
I can give her the world.
Well, that'll do.
And me, what do I get?
Session.
It's my pleasure to give you this coat of 100 everything.
After my daughter, my most prized possession.
Chief Togra, Kim, to help.
He and father were the friends. Yes, let's go ask him. Christian, he was just greeting us. It's the custom.
For a minute, I thought he'd chop off our heads. Ha ha. Oh, sh*t her. Oh, bleh! Ah, my dear Temujin, how surprising you're still alive.
Targrill, you and my father were friends. I need your warriors. Miguan stole my wife, Bote.
Miguan's powerful with all his warriors. You'll need many, many men. What will you give in return? Superb, yes, you will have them. Mm-hmm.
Why should we kill those who can be useful to us?
Mm-hmm.
Join me.
We'll give you power to your land.
Fight with me.
We'll give you victory over your enemies.
Pilgrim.
Men have agreed to join him.
And other tribes are rallying to him as well.
Dimogen is something of a nuisance.
I do wish you would say...
It would be an honor for me, Toggro.
An alliance against whom?
The Naaman.
Tackle the caravans.
It's impossible to carry on trade.
Yes.
They must be stopped.
Right.
Yes, I agree with you.
But we will travel a long and difficult road to victory.
Winter, Hemerjean and his troops crossed the Atai's tall place.
The grill traveled with them, in comfort befitting his high rank.
In a short time now, we will start the battle. We're ready.
Ogaday, my son, you will bring your archers into the center.
When you're in range of the enemy, you turn about and flee as if retreating.
Do you understand?
No problem.
Children turn into good Mongol warriors. It is a total victory.
a great warrior and a loyal servant what i am no one's servant things have gone too far go on do
it rid me of that nuisance oh yes monster's head emogen you united us all into one mongol people
you've courageously led us into battle and given us many glorious victories it is thanks to you
we have pasture land we have prairies as well as forests filled with game we proclaim you the emperor
The master of us all is Tangri, the eternal blue sky.
Genghis Khan could then create and command the greatest army that the world had ever seen.
Do your chin.
You sight the point right toward the target.
Easy for you to say.
Supply.
Sentry falls asleep.
Punishment is death.
100,000 horsemen.
Ten core and each of you to command.
Conquer the world.
At the same time, the French won a famous battle with only 1,000 horsemen.
Genghis Khan had 100,000.
The world might indeed tremble, and that's just what it did.
1207, all Mongolia, then southern Siberia, conquered.
1209, the conquest of northern Tibet.
The years, 1211 to 1215, the turn of China, including Peking.
1218, Kazakhstan is taken.
1220, in the war against Kwanzaan, lying near the Caspian Sea,
Genghis Khan assembles 200,000 horsemen warriors.
His enemies had even more in the battle.
22, the Caucasus, to the Black Sea, the Dnieper River.
Temujin, the poor, humble nomad, had made himself the great Genghis Khan,
master of the world, his empire spanned an entire continent,
all the way from China to the Caspian Sea.
He dominated such a vast territory or held so much power.
Then one day...
My son Ogudai, my children, faithful friends, I endow you all with my empire.
May you rule with wisdom and justice always.
Kublai, come.
A wise man has predicted a great future in store for you.
I was right.
And that child was to become the magnificent Kublai Khan.
Many years later, Marco Polo would write an account of the marvels of his court.